hello everyone and welcome to one of the
nicest games anyone ever played against
magnus carlsen it is from the 2020
norway championship and it is young
shisht of duda uh one of our candidates
versus magnus carlsen uh so it's a
really uh really uh a wild game you guys
will enjoy it some of you might have
seen it others that haven't will uh
really really uh enjoy this one so
without further ado let's check it out
it's duda with the white pieces and he
opens with e4 and magnus replies with c6
he goes for the carl khan defense uh
sorry about that
uh we have d4 uh d5 and now knight to c3
so going for the standard stuff captures
captures and now knight to f6 and yes as
you see as you can see i have returned
home and i'm ready uh for the candidates
tournament today is the opening ceremony
but the actual round one uh starts
tomorrow so knight of six we have knight
captures e captures and pawn to c3 uh
bishop to d6 by magnus and the bishop to
d3 we have castles and queen to c2 so
this is all very very standard we're
going after the h7 pawn rook to e8 to
check knight to e2 and now h5 grabbing
more space on the king side you can
maybe use it later on to create some
weaknesses but your pawn is no longer
hanging on h7 so bishop to e3 by duda
knight to d7 and now uh do the castles
queen side we have b5 by magnus and here
duda says all right that's quite an
expansion you're going for i'm just
going to undermine it with d5 this is a
bit of a problem because if captures of
course we're going to capture on b5 but
magnus says i i'm not interested in
capturing i'm just going to play pawn to
c5 i'm going to give up a pawn now just
make my attack happen a little bit
sooner so bishop captures on b5 you have
to capture this and now rook to b8 with
pawn to c4 and a6 now now clearing the b
file for the rook we've bishop to a4 and
here we have rook to e7 by magnus and it
is now as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
and the idea is pretty straightforward
you want to move the knight somewhere
let's say the e5 and then you want to
shift to this rook also to help out with
the attack along the b file so here duda
plays knight to g3 and the magnus goes
for knights to e5 immediately here after
the game was analyzed of course knight
to b6 was found to be the absolute
strongest idea
but it's um
if you don't see it right away it looks
really weird point is that after the
bishop moves somewhere uh we're gonna
capture this bishop on e3 we're going to
give up the exchange but our bishop pair
will be extremely strong if captures
were going to kick away the knight and
after the knight moves the bishop to g4
and carlson's bishop pair would
definitely have
compensation over the sacrifice rook but
okay after knight g3 magnus went for the
immediate knight to e5 and now this also
works if duda doesn't find the uh the
engine refutation of the move that is
bishop to d2 but it's such a silly move
to play and again it's uh
hard to realize why uh but uh
for one you will not be able to give up
the rook for bishop and also the bishop
from d2 guards the b4 and a5 squares
which are key squares in in carlson's
attack as as you'll see you'll see later
on so here it knights the e4 right away
by duda now comes rook e to b7 magnus
shifts the rook over to the queen side
b3 and now rook to b4 a move that would
not be possible if the bishop was on d2
but now uh
rook captures bishop is coming so that's
that's the whole point
we have bishop to d2 and now going after
the rook but now it doesn't really uh
do all that much here so rook captures
on a4 b captures and the bishop to f5
and now magnus definitely has
compensation for the sacrificed exchange
and he gets a position similar to the
one that that we've discussed so rook d
to e1 and ponte h4 now and here pawn the
h3 duda could also right away go for
rook to e3 rook h to e1 to double up on
d file but he first stops the h pawn uh
we have knight to g6 and now rook to e3
we have knight to f4 by magnus and now
pawn to g4 chasing the bishop away
bishop to g6 and now king to d1 getting
away from all the nasty checks because
knight to e2 and knight to d3 in the
future could be
quite quite strong for magnus so here f5
magnus wants to bust open the position
and continue his attack but now
duda could just capture the point yes
this opens up this diagonal but the king
does have
plenty of squares but first he goes for
the bishop knight captures and e6
because magnus is the one who's
attacking here uh it makes sense to
eliminate some of the attackers so queen
captures g captures on f5 and now bishop
to h5 with check and now if there wasn't
for this silly f3 move uh this would not
be
all that great for white however with
the inclusion of f3 uh the position is
actually very very good for duda so here
queen f6 magnus hopes to get some queen
a1 or maybe rook to b2 action but of
course just the bishop to c3 stopping
all of this we have queen to g5 now
uh threatening some discoveries here as
the rook is undefended uh but also
preventing rook to g1 so here rook h the
e1 does look like a move that fixes both
of those
ideas or rather that stops them but duda
goes for queen to e4 instead and now we
have uh
well we have a position where magnus
could play this king to h7 move uh and
uh be okay but it's again such a such a
weird move to play uh that um it's uh
it is just very hard to make it let's
say rook hd one f6 and black is
completely fine here there is no good
way for whites to actually threaten the
black king and black has all the time in
the world to organize uh some sort of uh
some sort of an attack here so instead
we have after queen to e4 queen to g2 by
magnus now rook h to e1 by duda and now
magnus
his position is is definitely worse and
he has to thread very carefully he has
to play something like f6 but then you
always have the past d-pawn to worry
about you could go for knight captures
an h3 create a pass pawn of your own and
try play it this way so there are uh
moves you can make to
achieve counter play here however after
carlson's move that is queen captures on
a2
there is just no going back but a very
very specific move is required from duda
to punish this uh uh queen captures an
a2 move so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this incredible
idea duda played while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that a
queen trade must be offered and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is queen to c2 such a such a
weird uh winning move but it's
absolutely crushing there is absolutely
nothing magnus can do here and it seems
like okay you can maybe play queen day
three you could trade queens you could
capture on c4 but none of none of this
is actually working if queen a3 you just
go under the mask of the
rook and after bishop captures on g7
your entire kingside is now busted you
have to move the queen we're going to
move the bishop back we're going to play
rook g1 check and we're going to
completely destroy black so that's one
option other option is to just trade
queens but magnus already sacrificed
material for the attack now he's just
down material and this is a completely
winning end game for dude of course he's
not going to do that so queen captures
on c4 but now comes the uh the absolute
beauty of the move queen queen to c4 uh
is the only move but it is uh it is
insufficient here rook to e8 with check
and the point of this move is that if
magnus captures we're gonna capture here
king the h7 will be magnus's only move
and now for the only winning move rook
to h8 with check that's the good stuff
uh putting the king on a dark square
and that's the only move and of course
once the king goes to a dark square
we're gonna deliver check and win the
black queen so this would happen
captures captures captures and captures
uh now it's a queen against the uh
bishop and the knight and of course
completely winning so magnus avoids this
he doesn't capture here he just goes a
king to h7 now his rook is kind of
guarding that h7 square uh but h8 square
but um uh well he he had to give up a
rook on b8 so rook cactus on b8 now
comes queen captures on d5 with check
queen to d2 again queen d2 only winning
move for duda you have to play this very
carefully bishop captures on f3 with
czech king to c1 and now comes a move
that you do not expect and that is queen
captures on f5 point is that if knight
to d3 check you don't
gain anything king to b1 and you can't
even capture the rook because the queen
would be hanging
or rather okay the queen is defended but
the problem is after knight captures on
uh e1 there's again rook to h8 that's
the that's the idea not that the queen
is hanging but actually black is getting
checkmated so here you have to capture
and after queen to h6 check as the g
point is pinned you just get check made
it so again rook to h8 ruins the day for
magnus so queen captures on f5 was
played and now rook to e3 we have knight
to e2 with check king to b2 and now
knight captures and c3 queen captures
are going after the bishop and now uh we
have queen to f4 uh attacking the rook
uh on b8 we have queen to d3 check f5
now and here rook
sorry rook to f8 going after the uh
df5 pawn and it's just that magnus is
down too much material but here uh the
king is still uh wide in the open so we
we're still gonna try so queen to be for
check we have king to c1 bishop to e4
now attacking the queen just queen b3
not allowing any uh silly ideas for
example if you offer a queen trade you
just get checkmated you don't want to do
that so here queen b3 we have queen to
d4 queen to c3 again forcing the black
queen back queen d6 going after the rook
rook f7 now threatening checkmate so the
queen has to go to help out with the
defense queen g6 now rook d7
and now the queen is pretty much stuck
here guarding the
g7 square so queen to g1 check we have
king to b2 and now pawn to c4 magnus
pushing pawns trying anything here to uh
you know make make something happen
because magnus is currently on his 125
unbeaten streak and duda could very well
ruin that for him so rook captures on e4
duda says all right now it's time to
trade no more uh uh
no more tricks for you uh
because without this bishop it's just a
very very easily winning f characters
and the rook d to e4 now we're going for
material we have queen f2 check queen to
d2 offering a queen trade c3 check king
captures and now queen to g3 with check
ensuring the capture of the h3 pawn king
to b2 we have queen captures on h3 and
now rook captures an e4 so now magnus is
down a full rook
but he still has a past h pawn a pass g
pawn he has to try queen g3 we have
queen to d4 and now queen to g2 with
king c3 queen f3 check king to b4 and
now queen to f8 with check king a5 and
now queen to f5 with check
king captures on a6 now pawn to g5 now
the two pass pawns are marching forward
a5 duda pushes his pawn as well h3 we
have rooked
uh e7 with check king g6 now comes queen
to g7 with check king h5 queen to h7
with check now again finally getting
that queen trade uh but the just king
the g4 here you could play a queen
captures an h7 rook captures uh but uh
then it's still sort of a race but not
really white wins this extremely easily
if you guys are wondering king g3 we're
gonna push the pawn uh push the pawn
pushed upon king g2 and after we bring
your queen into the game
it even comes with checks so uh
it's not even close so after this king
to g4 was played but now the uh absolute
strongest rook the e4 with check and he
was in this position on move 63 that
magnus carlsen resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here if
you move the king then you lose the
queen for nothing and of course if you
capture the rook then queen captures
duda is up a full queen
of course completely winning
so definitely one of the nicer games
people played against magnus in
classical and even though duda
defeated magnus in the norway
chess edition of 2020 magnus still won
the tournament in the end there was a
tie between him and alireza both nine
and a half but magnus won the won the
tie breaks so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it a little bit of
preparation for the candidates just to
see how people fared against magnus we
might show a few more before the actual
start of the candidates but uh you know
all it is and never defeated magnus for
example in classical chess
dinglira never defeated magnus in
classical chess so that's uh also really
really really important if it ever
gets
for one of them to actually win the
candidates tournament but
as we always say on this channel bobby
fischer never won a game uh classical
game against the boris posky before the
actual start of the world chess
championship match against boris posky
so that doesn't really have to you know
mean anything uh so once again hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
michael colbert and nagarjuna
narendra
jordan smith and uh sumindu sarkar for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
continuing uh to show some nice games
the candidates have played against
magnus carlsen uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and thank you all for
your birthday wishes i very much enjoy
reading all of them
see you soon